we spent
basically the entire period since the
middle ages you know with ups and downs
moving towards a society where if you
worked hard
and you and you developed a decent
number of skills you could live a modest
middle class lifestyle and you could
afford to raise a family and you could
afford maybe to have a little backyard
or a nice a nice flat
that
that was what we had achieved we by 1970
western societies japan as well had
achieved that goal and now we're moving
exactly away from it and if you think
that you can do that without there being
major social disruption i think
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine and this
is the show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is a
geographer and the author of a number of
books the latest of which is the coming
of neo-feudalism a warning to the global
middle class joel [ __ ] and welcome to
trigonometry oh it's my pleasure
uh it's really great to have you on
can't wait to discuss your book and
other things that you've written about
recently before we do though tell
everybody who are you how are you where
you are what has been the journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us
well i'm basically um i'm i grew up i
was born in germany my father was in the
army i uh grew up in new york um my
family's been in new york
since about 1900 so i have roots there
i moved to
california i went to the university of
california at berkeley
in the early 70s which was interesting
um and then i've been a journalist
basically all my life i've i've had
university think bank affiliations but
my mindset is that of a writer of the
journalists and you know one of the
things that's missing today is as we
keep trying to find
specialties so people write about this
and write about that but they don't
write about the big picture you know
it's like sorokin wrote many years ago
that we we
know more and more about less and less
um and i think that's where we're you
know where we we've headed
i think of myself as just a writer um
and if you say who
would i consider you know role models or
people that i would
would uh
look up to would be people like de
tocqueville um weber
um
but many people who were not necessarily
academics one of the interesting things
in the last few years
is that many of the really interesting
books are not coming from academia
they're coming from outside and you know
when i wrote the the history of cities
which was published all over the world
um it was really interesting to me then
i said well how come you asked me and
they said because you know you write in
this strange language called english
in a way that people can understand
um
and i think that that role as a writer
as as somebody without a particular
political affiliation without an
ideological uh sort of stamp
that
kind of of
person and function in society is really
diminished in the last 50 60 years what
we used to call public intellectuals
that almost don't exist anymore and i
think that
whether or not that could be revived or
not is going to be a big question
well we're grateful that you exist and
many of our former and upcoming guests i
would say are public intellectuals um
and it's that's one of the reasons it's
such a pleasure to have you on the show
i was gonna get straight into the new
feudalism stuff but you you peaked my
curiosity
by talking about berkeley in the 70s
what have you seen in the last 50 years
that's been happening to our society
that stands out for you since those days
in particular oh boy
well i think there's some good things
and some bad things i mean i think
certainly attitudes
towards um
uh you know race towards
gay people have certainly improved um
considerably maybe
maybe gone a little bit um overboard in
some areas but but you know basically i
think those are improvements i think the
the
offerings if you can afford them of
quality of food quality of certain kind
of uh entertainment experiences that
that's gone on i lived in los angeles in
1975 of the bay uh southern california i
know we moved to orange county six years
ago but
um but you know living here los angeles
when i moved there it was in a lot of
ways more endearing than it is today but
the food is better the culture is better
it's a more
uh there's certainly much more
integration of particularly hispanic and
and and asian americans in the society
so there are some improvements the
negatives
the spirit of intellectual debate is
being squashed
um the rise of the
of the oligarchic um tech companies and
their wall street backers
are
constraining a speech constraining
how people talk and even in some cases
as i you know as a parent i notice
they've had a very negative effect in
many ways on younger people in the sense
of you know tying them more and more to
their phones and and and making it a
little bit more difficult for them to
relate to other people and obviously on
the education side um it's a disaster i
mean the
the kind of standards that we had um at
let's say at berkeley um or in almost
any school
in 40 50 years ago people actually read
books
i don't know if you've noticed that like
right now if i assign
three books four books for a class um
maybe they'll get read a lot of them
won't get read and um
and sometimes you'll you'll in the past
i could have eight or nine books in the
and they would read the books i mean so
what we're doing is we're sort of
you know even as we're technologically
advancing in many ways we're socially
and intellectually regressing
that's a bad combination
it is i agree with you and so speaking
of what you're talking about in your
book which is essentially the
ever-growing gap not only in wealth and
income but also in influence and power
between a small elite and everybody else
a friend of mine who's a fan of the show
sent me a a
a graph earlier today which was the
genie coefficient uh for the western
world and it's literally like a line
like this for the last 60 years
basically so the rich are getting richer
or the rich part of society is getting
richer and the poor part of society is
not
anything like the same rate and what you
talk about is the logical end product of
that process right right right and and
which is already you know clear like
you know you think about how we discuss
let's say the issue of urban renaissance
or the favorite topic of
the progressive elites and and also the
real estate interests including many
from the right
well what they're writing about is the
world that they live in like when i was
working on a project in london
um yes there are some of the richest
precincts in the world and certainly in
the uk are in london
but if you bother to go outside of the
of those areas actually there's also
some of the highest rates of poverty in
all of
of uh europe i mean it's not even
you know it you know you see that in new
york where they'll say oh the city's
come back and yes in certain areas but
the poorer areas have become poorer
and many of the middle class suburban
areas went through somewhat of a decline
so you know it that what what we have is
we have a media that
functions um in in a way
but
that gives us a very distorted picture
of what's actually going on in the
society um and how things are reported i
mean my my wife has to listen to me when
i well i i can't sometimes i can't even
read the new york times i'll read a
piece and say where was the editor did
they ever think that maybe there's
another point of view or maybe to
question it particularly on issues like
race climate gender
it it is like
you know it is newspeak now i mean it's
just like you cannot you can't you you
can't even acknowledge that there's
another side uh you can't acknowledge
that maybe there's some nuance here so i
just find the intellectual uh
environment you know very very difficult
and i have no by the way i have no
sympathy for the far right at all i you
know and they're just as bad it's just
that they don't they don't have the big
megaphones
and it's it's a great point and what
these people on the left and don't seem
to understand is that
by doing these pieces by ridiculing
people by not letting people into the
conversation
all you're doing is emboldening them
and you're radicalizing them they don't
seem to understand this that's a really
big point i'm actually working on an
essay right now
you know talking about president biden's
just bizarre policies of
you know we're going to help you know
we're going to have special programs to
help people by by their racial
characteristic basically you know black
um
well in a country where hispanics are
now much more numerous and asians may
eventually be more numerous um what are
you going to do are you going to have
racial uh vetting for for positions it's
are we going to decide that then that
the number of pilots has to be
x percentage to match some other
percentage in the population i mean this
is this is sort of the direction that
we're going and and your point
i think this is one of the biggest uh
spurs for white nationalism i mean look
i'm in what we would say in yiddish i'm
an old takaka i'm going to be 70 next
year so i'm
you know
i i've had a pretty good run as much of
my generation
i look behind me and i say if i were a
young
a white male in trying to get a job in a
corporation today
i realized that i'm i'm i'm in a race
with with with lead weights on my feet
now if that's the case which i think in
many cases it isn't
those people are going to be resentful
and you're going to sow
racial resentment by by establishing
uh racial quotas in societies like the
uk like the us like australia like
canada that have had some terrible
racist past
but
had moved to a position where they were
making sure that there was no
discrimination now we're moving to a
different kind of discrimination that
can only create an ever more angry
society on both the minority point of
view and in
the the um let's say the native born
predominantly white population
it's
it's a recipe for social chaos
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthem has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
it is a recipe for social calves and the
other problem is joel saying to these
people you know you're lucky you're
privileged and they're going around
going well look wages haven't increased
in real time inflation's through the
roof and by the way i'm probably never
going to be able to own a property right
right when this is the end and this is
an issue that i would say if the left
focused on
issues of
upward mobility and how to make life
better for for people irrespective of
the race you know
why should we have a system
where a kid from appalachia
in which there has been generations of
poverty or in the north of england
you know in some coal mining town where
things have not gone well for 50 years
or more
why is that child who's brought up in
very difficult circumstances very
similar circumstances
up to an inner city minority population
how do you get that population
um
and and say to them you're privileged
but the you know
many of um african-americans and and
certainly other uh minorities
are upper middle class or middle class
and and are doing fine i mean you can't
if you you really got to approach it
from a class point of view from a class
perspective of how do you raise the
the lower classes how do you raise the
working class to middle class how do you
provide incentive for the middle class
to work hard
and and and and provide for themselves
that whole sort of
gestalt of politics that dominated much
of american and and european politics is
being
transformed by an obsession on climate
and obsession on on race and an
obsession on gender which by the way is
heavily funded by the oligarchs because
as long as we're not talking about class
as long as we're not talking about the
fact that maybe it's not a great idea
that microsoft controls 90 of the
operating systems on computers
as long as
talk about
race talk about about transgender talk
about
you know how the culture should should
um
relate to certain groups
that isn't what we should be discussing
the real problem in in in the us and and
around the western world and
increasingly in east asia certainly soon
in china is this class divide and if we
don't figure out a way to provide
younger people with something close to
the opportunities that our generation
had my generation had i think we're in
for a lot of trouble of and coming from
different
and
directions
when i think about feudalism i sort of
see a game of thrones type of world
right and one of the features of course
is that if you're born into the royal
family let's say you're going to stay in
the royal family you're going to be rich
and powerful and influential in that
world and if you're born a peasant
you're going to die a peasant if you're
born a blacksmith's son you're going to
the best you can be is a blacksmith
right
are you are you genuinely seeing that
kind of future for us where your parents
and their station in life almost
pre-determines your outcomes well let's
put it this way upward mobility is more
difficult
right you mentioned property probably
the most important way that the middle
and working classes have traditionally
developed wealth i mean you think about
my mother or my mother-in-law
as they as they got into their 80s and
90s it was that property that allowed
them to retire
not on subsistence but
with a certain degree of comfort
that next generation isn't going to have
that opportunity in large numbers
particularly who can afford i i live in
in you know orange county one of the
nicest places you could ever want to
live in many ways but
you know a a house here is going to cost
even
at the bottom maybe eight nine hundred
thousand dollars
and a decent house and a good school
district is going to probably run you
over a million how many people
who do not have wealthy parents are
going to be able to afford that so what
you're seeing is like when you poll
people you say young people say well how
are you going to buy a house the biggest
um factor now is inheritance you know
that literally you can you know so that
like for instance if you like i have a
friend who who is selling real estate in
brooklyn and
in a very nice part of brooklyn and and
what she tells me is that half the
over half the people over 45 under 45 um
have to have co-signing parents
so if you're from a poor family exactly
how are you going to get in this market
so
so what we have to figure out is how do
we expand ownership how do we expand
entrepreneurship how do we expand
um opportunity now i think
this is what democrats should be talking
about and what the labor party in in the
uk should be talking about the labor
party in in australia should be talking
about and the liberals in canada should
be talking about but they're not
they're talking about about transgender
issues and whether you know what a woman
is and and they that they're talking
about you know what i i don't know
particular position and i'm just like
this is with their obsession you know
systemic racism um
canceling people who may have said
something that somebody somewhere may
have found remotely offensive you know
having special programs for people by
skin color this is a terrible agenda
defunding the police i mean that's a
particular issue here
um adopting climate policies where the
rich who push for extreme climate
policies are not affected
the what they're saying is you've got to
cut back so i'm i'm going to be told
by by jeff bezos you've got to you've
got to reduce your carbon footprint
here's a guy who's whose company's
carbon footprint is probably bigger than
some app those of some african countries
and and and you've got a guy who's got
four or five houses you know god knows
what okay i i don't i don't begrudge him
i mean i think i've met jeff i think
he's a really smart guy and you know and
he has created a terrific product unlike
some of the other people who have may
also made a lot of money but but but the
reality is
you know if you're going to address
climate change you can't have it in a
situation at very medieval i have to say
where the rich buy indulges oh well i
bought you know 3 000 acres of woodlands
in in in brazil so therefore i can fly
in in my own private jet and then worry
about climate change but you better not
get on that on on that ryanair flight
from from from london to
to to spain for your one week of of of
sunshine um that that you look forward
to all year i mean it's
you you have to if you're going to make
a change you have to look at what the
the the
effects are
on working people on the poor
we you know we for instance we go to
africa and we say to africa
no no fossil fuels
well here's a continent where
electricity is in short supply and
there isn't going to be a enough wind
and solar to power those economies as
their populations as one place in the
world with the population's growing
we're not even thinking about the
effects i'll give you a great little
story i had a i got a i got a
once in a while you know i don't know if
you probably have these you know people
embedded in these
increasingly insane organizations
occasionally they contact you and say
can i talk to you so i talked to this
guy
um
a phd candidate at stanford working on
electric vehicles and he said
well so
here's here's my situation i'm working
on electric vehicles
and i you know he's okay with it
but he says every time i ask the
question where's the power going to come
from they say don't worry about it
and he said
like i said i'm an engineer i'm taught
to say well if i do x there's going to
be y now do i mitigate it is
it you know what are the effects going
to be that's what i'm supposed to be
doing as an engineer and he's told not
to do it the the group think the the
desire to make to not ask questions i i
read newspaper accounts
and i just i say
you know
but i said we had fires here in
california uh now now there are lots of
reasons we've had fires in california
for a very long time actually we have
less of the big urban fires than than we
used to have but okay the fires are
climate change no climate change might
be part of it but there are there were
very detailed reports from
from state commissions let's say a lot
of it was the the policies that the
greens imposed on fires they wouldn't
let them take out the old growth and
that was very combustible
what a reporter should be looking at
both of these issues they should be
talking about the climate and what the
effect might be and also maybe are we
doing something wrong on the policy side
are there other reasons why these things
happen than just to say oh it's the
climate crisis so now we're like
medieval
clerics running around saying
every bad thing to have every time
there's a drop of rain that happens at a
time it shouldn't happen or every time
the temperature is higher i always find
it interesting that every time we have
high temperatures there's major coverage
and when there's low temperatures we
have very little now look i believe that
there's climate change i think it's
probably likely that there's something
going on
and we but we but instead of thinking
about how do we adapt to it we're
deciding that we're going to punish the
peasants and make and and make them you
know essentially pay for the the uh
obsessions of of the of the aristocrats
i mean
you know it's really
to me it's just it's just incredible how
we sit there and we think about making
major transitions that are just
absolutely against the interest of a
large portion the majority portion of
western societies and at the same time
we're depriving uh the opportunity to
advance further for the parts of the
world that are the majority of the world
which are developing countries it it's
just astounding to me that we that that
we don't even seem to consider this
um in
in discussions because you know
basically um governments in in most
cases uh and increasingly are run as
technocracies and
you know to them every every problem has
to be solved in a particular way and we
don't consider like for instance here in
california they say well we want to cut
greenhouse gases so everybody has to
live in an apartment in a dense area now
besides the fact that that science there
is actually not very good
the the reality is if you're telling a
whole generation that they're never
going to own a house that they're going
to have to pay high rents
um and and that there's there's no way
that they're ever going to have what
they want what do they expect what kind
of society do you think you're going to
have you think you're going gonna have a
bunch of happy campers
well you know you better be selling soma
on a massive level if you want that to
happen
right uh and joel one of the things you
just talked about is ideology and i'm
sure that's a big part of some of the
things that are happening but when we
talk about the housing crisis
particularly here in the uk where it's
very pronounced yes i also think i talk
about this in my book a little bit as
well because what i see there is yes
partly it's about ideology but partly
now it's all about the incentives people
who own property like me right have
absolutely no personal short-term
incentive to see that problem fixed
because we benefit because we are now
part of like we've got our foot on the
ladder and as the ladder moves up and
further away from everybody else we're
going to be propelled with it and screw
all the guys over there right and he's
pointing at me joel by the way i don't
own property and that's how will stay
but
exactly
he's the peasant
so francis is going to remain a serve
which is good but my broader point is
like we've got to a position where none
of us seem to be thinking about anything
beyond our own personal short-term
interest and i've just had
my wife and i just had our first child
and it's already shifting the way i
think about this because i'm now
thinking about
other people the future it's not just
about me what is going to be the case
when my son is 40 years old right
but we don't make decisions as a society
on that basis we don't think about what
the housing crisis is doing to the
marriage rate what it's doing to the
average age of the first time mother
what it's doing to us as a society the
point that you make if everybody's
living in a flat share with five other
people in the city with no access to
nature no access to their own property
etc what is that actually gonna do to
human brains and human behavior and the
stuff that spills out into the streets
we only think about the short term right
here right now what benefit to me
well we have you know we certainly have
that here i mean
there is a lot a strange alliance and i
think you have this in the uk as well
the upper class of property owners
are also the biggest environmentalists
because they they don't want to see
development you know they don't want you
know somebody to build you know 10 000
houses in essex
you know they don't want to do that
because they they know that if that that
that means that my property which has
gone
due to no intelligence of my own has
gone from let's say very common here is
to talk california being you know
probably one of the epicenters of all
this
you know
people who bought a house for 150 200
000
30 years ago
it's now worth a million and a half
why would i you know why would i want to
give this up so
the the the danger we is also that much
of the property is now owned by people
who don't have children or
um or their children are already gone so
they they don't really care
um and and so i think that we we do have
a
nobody is really looking at the few or
not nobody but most people are not
really looking at a future that i think
is socially sustainable we can't have a
society in which you know if we go 20 30
years from now and let's say in the uk
homeownership goes from
let's say 50
to 30
do you think that's a state that's going
to be a stable society i mean we spent
basically the entire period since the
middle ages you know with ups and downs
moving towards a society where if you
worked hard
and you and and you developed a decent
number of skills you could live a modest
middle class lifestyle and you could
afford to raise a family and you could
afford maybe to have a little backyard
or a nice
a nice flat
that that was what we had achieved we
had by 1970
western societies japan as well had
achieved that goal and now we're moving
exactly away from it and if you think
that you can do that without there being
major social disruption i think you're
wrong
can i just pick up on one other point
that you made earlier which is about the
environmental stuff um and we've got net
zero here in the uk and anyone who says
anything about how this may cause some
problems is automatically a climate
change denier and all of that rubbish i
i i'm pretty convinced climate change is
happening i'm pretty convinced it's
caused by human activity to some extent
uh but i also don't think impoverishing
the people who are already poor in
societies is the answer and the main
point i wanted to raise with you is what
you said about technocracy because if
you had a referendum on net zero in the
uk
i don't think you would get over 20
personally i mean i haven't seen the
polling but i don't think it's a popular
thing to do particularly when you
explain to people how much is going to
cost them but we've never had any public
conversation about whether this is an
approach that we want to take or not is
kind of foisted on us by the politicians
and
like no one really particularly cares
what the ordinary person thinks they
don't particularly care what the polling
is even
it's just something that the people who
are smarter and more you know
respectable than us have decided that we
must do and that's it
well i think we're moving towards is
that i think that you're exactly right i
mean
you take here in in california governor
newsom basically says we're going to get
rid of we're going to every we're going
to get rid of gas car the gas industry
we're going to wipe out 300 000 jobs
because california by the way sits on a
pool of oil and gas
nobody noticed but
john paul getty's wealth comes from that
in part
um
but but the reality is
what what we what we do is we say okay
we're going to everyone's going to have
to have evs now the problem is evs are a
expensive
um
god knows where the electricity is going
to come from
and if you know the economies of places
like south and east l.a or or oakland
they're filled with car repair stores
people
check you know constantly working on
their cars there's a whole car culture
you'd never get that through the
legislature
you would have a huge problem you just
you just say see what coveted the the
one of the worst parts about the covet
is it put in place
a dictatorial regime would say it's good
for you we're taking care of you we now
have the head of the epa talking about
not only are we do we want to
call people who have any question on
climate science we're going to basically
kick them off social media
anybody who disagrees how to deal with
climate
that disagrees from the party line they
should be excluded too that's where
we're headed
um and
and you know the you know when i teach a
class on on the future
and
the book that i think holds up best is
uh huxley's uh brave new world i think
you know if huxley knew about digital
technology he'd probably have it all
right it's sort of like we have a
society which is increasing control by a
managerial elite you know what burnham
wrote about um
you know this sort of idea of there
being
a uber class who know best and what and
they are empowered by this very wealthy
aristocratic class who supports them now
whether or not these two classes what i
call the clarissa and and and the
oligarchs whether they will continue to
to uh
uh be able to be in harmony that's going
to be very interesting to see it is
astounding to me by the way that net
zero is being imposed by a conservative
regime it's kind of remarkable
um if the if the labor rights were smart
they they would oppose it but they're
probably the problem is that that that
climate change orthodoxy is so powerful
on the left i think they won't be able
to do it they'll probably say oh no we
have to get the net zero tomorrow not
not you know 20 years from now
oh absolutely isn't the problem joel
this we
are addicted to offering
simple solutions to incredibly complex
problems yes that's what we're doing all
the time that's what all discussions
seem to be about
oh i think that's exactly right i think
that's really
you know like you know people say
what okay a guy's running for mayor of
los angeles uh you know i don't know if
he'll win or not rick caruso who's a you
know fairly middle-of-the-road candidate
and the la times starts ranting and
raving about well you know he's he's uh
he doesn't have a climate plan he's
mayor the city is overrun with homeless
people we have a crime wave the city has
some of the worst economic numbers of
any in the united states today a city
that should be booming it's you know
it's it's the the world's large only
mega city that's in an absolutely
perfect climate okay that's that's what
southern california is
and and and we're worried about whether
whether you know what you mean he's
gonna have a climate change policy we're
thinking about
one city if the state of california fell
into the ocean tomorrow
it would have it would make up for maybe
what china does in two months
in terms of increasing emissions i mean
this idea of there being
you know well the uk is going to prove
how great we are
meanwhile
china's just you know i wrote a piece
recently calling it you know the
rope-a-dope strategy i don't know you're
probably too young to remember muhammad
no no no no we remember yeah yeah
absolutely ollie versus foreman
okay
well you know the bottom line is
the the
the chinese are playing us brilliantly
and the indians aren't far behind
they're saying oh yeah we'll we'll get
to net zero but we're going to get to it
by the time we get to it your economies
will have been destroyed your english
economy is already basically
you know moving in this direction you'll
be financial services media and and a
great vacation spot for wealthy chinese
that's that's your future if you keep
going the way you're going because if
england gives up the uk gives up
its
industrial and and energy production
industries
and becomes you know tries to go this
sort of net zero route
and it and while china basically
supplies all the products you know
that's the other thing we we looked at
this in california oh yeah we can reduce
um
uh we can reduce um the emissions in
california by a sending people and
companies
to other parts of the country so how
does it benefit the climate if a cement
works leaves la
where the customers are right there
and moves to arizona or mexico where
they have to truck it in you know it's
it makes no sense
it's not even the the weird thing is the
climate policies i think in many cases
are more about social control and the
vision
that
many of the the left and particularly
the progressive have have had and some
conservatives have had for decades for
decades
if if if you want to know
you know basically
these
the the the people who are now the
dominant powers in our society
really
you know aren't really i don't think
they're thinking very clearly because at
some point the middle and working
classes will push back
and and it may not be very pretty when
they do
and that's the worry joe that they are
gonna push back because here's the thing
if you're playing a game and you have no
chance of winning
then there's no incentive to play the
game and in fact there's quite a lot of
incentive
as a five-year-old would do this game is
rigged to grab the board and flip it
right
right
yeah i think that's that and i think
that that i mean that's why you get
these strange results in elections today
like
electing donald trump how could that
happen
bernie sanders would have been the
democratic nominee had the oligarchy and
the party establishment
not rallied behind biden
um
uh and and essentially forced everybody
else out of the race
you could have had a socialist against
the limit
um in
in 2020.
the
the anger at the grassroots level is
very strong you look at the recent
elections in france um my wife's
family's from france so i kind of follow
it
um
melanchol a far left trotskyite
may have been the his his group may have
been the biggest winners in the
legislative election
uh le pendens and more far right
candidates got they got about 20 25 too
so at least half the population of
france is rejecting any kind of
liberal capitalism
all right joel i hear you uh our
audience are very familiar with these
arguments because we've explored them at
length because we like you think these
are really important issues that are
coming they're already here that are
affecting our lives today
what the hell did we do about it
okay now that i think unfortunately i
don't think either political party will
has the answer in our country or your
country for that matter yeah agreed
so somehow a
sort of radical center has to emerge and
um and i don't know how
how it could be done
um
we've seen some of the possibilities um
sometimes when we get a candidate a
particular candidate who is um
either brilliant politically like bill
clinton was i think
i i voted for clinton twice myself um
i mean there are bad parts about clinton
but there are a lot of really good parts
um and they're they're occasionally
candidates like what rick caruso is
trying to do in la
is
you know bring a centrist position in
but it's very difficult the
the thing that's really surprising me
and i trying to understand it is why our
oligarchs and their you know their
ex-wives and their offspring
why are they adopting the most extreme
possible positions
um why why are oligarchs why did they
support a d.a
in san francisco who's allowed one of
the great cities of the world to become
accessible i don't get it they live
there
doesn't it bother them doesn't it bother
them that there are whole parts of the
city you can't go to doesn't it bother
them that san francisco has more drug
addicts than than high school students
you think that you think that's
that's the ideal
i mean i look at these people and they
say
if if your vision of the world is san
francisco today
then i don't want a part of it
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy dns is a company for you easy dns
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancer culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies
he knows about that so will you in a
second easy dns have rock-solid network
infrastructure and fantastic customer
support they're in your corner no matter
what the world throws at you unless it's
your ex-girlfriend in which case you're
on your own you know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is go to easy dns dot com forward slash
triggered that's easy dns.com forward
slash triggered use our promo code which
is also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for the
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
so but give us a how do we you talk
about radical centrism that's that's
music to my is because that's kind of
what i think about
how do we deal with this joel because
look you've written books about this
you're very persuasive in
diagnosing the problem but it's up to
people like you and people like us and
other guests on our show to start to
chart some of the way out of this
malaise
right so give us something
well i'm i'm working on some of the
ideas i'm begging you can you not say
i'm begging you give us a way out well
first of all we have to get away from
the ideal ideology you know i'm writing
an essay about this right now daniel
bell great sociologist you know wrote
the most important book in many ways of
the 20th century was the rise of
post-industrial society
um the coming post-industrial society
but
bell also wrote a book called the end of
ideology and around 1960
it looked like ideology was dying that
you know parties differed but there
wasn't you know there was not a basic
agreement about what we wanted
um
now we're
ideology has come back and we have to
get away from this sort of one you know
there's only one thing that really
matters you know race gender
you know the climate you know these
issues which are
ramped up to some hysterical level we
have to say what what really works like
you know governor newsom here in
california you know signed this
reparations bill besides the fact that
california was never a slave state
what you know um
and there were about 1200 slaves in in
california when when uh
when the state um
joined the union
um
the bottom line is
that
we have economic policies that make
african-american incomes based if you
based on cost
lower than they are in mississippi
tell me what is so great about a
reparations bill when you have a state
that's expelling its own black
population san francisco is
a
has a fraction of the black population
it used to have they they uh somebody
even wrote
made a movie called the last black man
in san francisco
and i remember because i went to school
in the bay area and i worked in the bay
area
i remember when there was a very vital
black community in san francisco it's
almost gone now
and yet the same people are saying you
have to adopt our policies but your
policies are causing this your policies
are causing poverty your policies are
making homeownership for the next
generation and minorities and immigrants
more difficult
why is it
that that minorities and immigrants are
moving to texas
it was supposed to be the the center of
racism and and reaction
well
yeah there is a lot of racism and
reaction probably still in texas but you
know what
if if i'm if i'm a young minority couple
or an immigrant couple or a millennial
and i can go and i can buy a nice
townhouse in a decent area for 175 200
000 dollars in west houston is that
better than living in a crate in san
francisco or l.a
i think people jolt so is that part of
the answer because i know i'm probably
annoying you by focusing on this but i
do think it's up to to us to start
formulating some of the answers i agree
one of the things i really admire about
the united states particularly during
covet when we had a pretty hardcore you
know this is good for you so you can't
do anything kind of policy over here
there were states in the united states
which you can argue whether they took a
better approach or a worse approach but
you as a free citizen of the united
states had a choice you want to be freer
go to florida go to texas you want to be
quote unquote safer stay in new york
city stay in in california right is that
the answer really here where at least in
the like we can't move if we don't like
the tax policy in the uk we can't move
to belgium you know not least because we
don't want to live in belgium but you
see what i'm saying like
the
at least you guys have the opportunity
to offer different ways of doing things
and people can then vote with their feet
is that going to be part of the answer
here yes i i that's an excellent part
and and frankly i think people you know
within reason
should be able to have the kind of
communities that they they want to have
i mean now
there obviously are going to be health
and safety issues that are that are
universal but
you know to me the idea that somebody
wants to have a
um
a community where um
you know more traditional values are are
taught in the schools
and then there's another school district
that wants to
to make malcolm x's birthday a holiday
you know i'm this is a line that uh i
think norman manley used when he was
running for new mayor of new york many
years ago um the bottom line is
we should allow it this this was the
genius of the american constitution and
by the way there's quite a bit of
autonomy um historically both in canada
and on australia as well um i mean i
think it has something to do with the
fact that
that
you went through very different
evolution than we did and and
and also these are big places with lots
of room and people can can move from one
place to the other fairly easily the the
the tragedy to me and here's part of
what i would do is if i was in the uk
you really want to
see more activity outside of london you
have the more you concentrate everything
in one place it becomes very expensive
um and it expels
um a lot of industry because it has to
go elsewhere i mean if you take a look
at what's happening in the tech scene in
in europe it's moving to the to the east
because uh
because
it's too expensive uh to be to be in you
know to be in london or paris so i think
one of the things that decentralization
is going to be important uh imp i think
a lot of it has to do with
self-sufficiency so let's like for
instance milton friedman actually had a
very good idea which was a negative
income tax instead of a basic income
let's incentivize people to work i don't
think somebody who's working at home
depot for forty thousand dollars or
thirty thousand dollars a year should be
paying
a lot of income tax they they really you
know actually they should be given
incentive on the other hand i don't want
to see what many of the oligarchs want
which is to turn the vast majority of
the population into a bunch of sort of
mindless sir you know serves who who
cash a check maybe occasionally
drive an uber that that's not the vision
that's going to hold the society
together um so i think we have to
incentivize work we have to make it much
easier for families um like for instance
okay instead of having a giant
bureaucracy to raise children
why don't we allow you know grandma to
get a little bit of a stipend to to
watch the child the kid if the if the
wife or husband has to go out to work
need somebody to substitute
let's think about how do we preserve
institutions like the family how do we
preserve the the the
the chance for entrepreneurship and
property for the next generation those
are the issues that that a that we need
to be addressing and i don't see that
happening anywhere i i you know i think
the right is is it in many cases just
enslaved to capital you know anything
they do is okay and of course you know
google could buy the american right for
one-fifth of what they give to the to
the left so
you know that you know that you'll
you'll have that
the the right it has doesn't have the
answers the left doesn't have the
answers the answers are going to be what
is it that people actually want what is
it that that that how do we help people
reach their aspirations that's what we
should be focusing on that's what i as a
traditional democrat that's what i
always thought was important you know
whether
you know if you look at um harry truman
pat brown
uh
even to some extent bill clinton the
great appeal of bill clinton
is clinton understood
having been a governor of arkansas
coming from a poor background he
understood that you appealed to people
saying if you work play by the rules
you should have this
now we have an admin a a democratic
party says you can go you can commit
crimes you could you you could you you
could be disobedient in school you could
be disruptive you could do this you
could do that but you're still going to
get the check
right you have rights and entitlements
as opposed to opportunities exactly and
and so
somebody who's a working class person
working at home depot working at walmart
working at
at at the corner drugstore whatever
that person needs to be empowered that
person needs to be respected
um
and you know and not be treated although
how much carbon do you emit you know
like
what what kind of
vision of humanity is that
we can and then you know on the climate
issue i would say look
it doesn't matter what the uk in the u.s
does we've already reduced our emissions
by a lot and we you know we can continue
to do it over time but china and india
and africa are not going to be on that
i'm not going to do that and that's
where the emissions are going to grow so
yes we should try to limit our emissions
in a reasonable way but we don't have to
destroy our societies in the process and
we can't kid ourselves that we live in a
world in which europe and america can
determine what's going to happen to the
planet that's over it's been over for 50
years already wake up
and and we're not doing that we're we're
we're living you know and i think a lot
of it is like i don't
it doesn't matter if california reduces
emissions 25 or 27
it doesn't matter because china and
india will wipe that out
in
know a very very short period of time
we need to be thinking about adaptation
you know i'm so tired of people saying
well the seas are going to rise i said
well why don't you propose sea walls uh
we're going to not have enough water
well maybe we should do desalination
here in california maybe we ought to a
friend of mine at mit is talking about
why don't we build a channel since the
midwest seems to be flooding more often
why don't we
relieve them of their flood waters and
move them to the southwest in in the
canal you know when you think about what
what the the chinese emperors did in
ancient times what the romans did with
their roads with with what we did here
in the united states and what you did in
the uk with canals why aren't we even
thinking about how do we adapt the dutch
learned how to adapt
because of the um you know they
obviously have a secret level uh issue
and have for for a long time
we can adapt why aren't we talking about
adapting to something that we can't
fundamentally change because the dynamic
of climate change is going to come from
china and the developing world for the
next 20 or 30 years
we should do our our best but to destroy
our societies in the process um i think
doesn't do anyone any good
job it has been a wonderful interview
thank you very much before we go we
always end with our final question which
is what is a one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be
i would say more than than anything else
what we really need to be talking about
is
the
impact
of social media on
discussion in general and the lack of
of of just good common
discussion you know i
i've noticed over the years that there
are many outlets which i used to do all
the time i know my views haven't changed
at all
cnn msnbc
uh npr
you know
i wrote for the new york times i wrote
for the washington post i i worked for
the la times
very difficult to get into those places
anymore if you have a contrarian point
of view very very difficult
sometimes i get i i sneak my way into
the la times but that's about it
um
you know i think that i think that what
what what we have is
a a an environment where social media is
sort of pushing people to the extremes
and the
legacy media which should be
sort of the arbiter and trying to be
sort of in between
has decided to start go on one side and
so that discussion itself has gotten
weaker and that's why we come up with
you know with with ideologies that make
no sense in terms of reality
yeah well you're right i also think
though that there's an emerging new
thing which is social media lets us down
by creating tribalism legacy media is
taken aside for the most part as you say
but i also think there's a new thing
emerging which is what we're doing right
here which is actually trying to have a
conversation that increasingly people i
think are hungry for do you see some
cause for optimism there yes i do i i
mean i i see the rise not just of you
know podcasts like this but but uh
you know what what's what's being done
on on sub stack
you know andrew sullivan ari weiss
that's a very positive development
of publications like you know and of
course i write for them unheard spiked
um
quillette
um these are these are new ventures and
yes they're not gigantic but because
they are they they are places where i
can sit there and say okay i'm not being
i'm not i'm not listening to some you
know ideologically driven
presentation i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm getting
it uh interesting point of view so i i
think that that that there are some
signs i think there's a there is a
rebellion
among traditional liberals against what
the woke of have imposed i think that is
becoming very obvious and what's going
to be interesting here in the united
states after the 2022 elections
what let's just say the republicans pick
up 25 seats unfortunately most of those
seats will be from more moderate
democrats
who nancy pelosi has sacrificed um and
the question will be well does the party
go further left or further right
does it go back to the center or does it
you know did they and whether they're
capable of learning anything is of
course a
you know an open question
joel do you think institutions like the
washington post the la times and new
york times
do you think they can be saved or do you
think the
it's now we have to create our own
institutions we have to do it via
substance we have to do it via podcasts
like this
i i don't i i don't see how you turn
these around i
i i watch
in amazement you know i
um i did a uh
um i was doing some stuff on the la
election so i said oh i wonder you know
i have a subscription a digital
subscription to the la times oh i'll see
what the la times is saying it was so
incredibly biased
for
you know karen bass the former vince
ramos
uh person who's probably going to be the
next mayor good chance she'll be the
next mayor
uh
and against caruso favoring
all the you know you think the san
francisco chronicle supports boudin you
know the the d.a i mean the um i think
these these institutions have been so
penetrated now
and that there's this whole generation
of young journalists who have been
uh who have been trained to think that
their job is not to inform as we were
taught at in the old days uh or to give
people options
is to instruct to to push in a certain
direction very much like
um
let's just say would be the case with
the old pravda in the uh in the soviet
union that's that's really
and and and you know what happens is as
the old mostly liberal editors retire
die off whatever
and there's there's no there's nobody
left who says you know you really have
to
tell both sides you really you know i
mean i know because i read these stories
and i said well didn't the editor say
you should talk to somebody
who maybe thinks that there's something
else going on you know whatever you know
particularly if it's race gender climate
uh anything involving trump
and i think trump is a awful human being
and the country would be infinitely
better off if he didn't exist and he'd
be infinitely better off if he didn't
run and he'd be infinitely better off if
he was disgraced
but
the coverage was so venomous and so unb
you know so biased so
you know things that you would say well
how you know you can't say that in in in
a in a newspaper account without
sounding like you're writing something
for the democratic national committee
that those boundaries have just they've
collapsed almost completely
i mean it it you almost sometimes can
feel well here's what the party line is
and all of a sudden the coverage is all
about the party line i mean it's
astounding and the fact that that
dissenting voices are either eliminated
or put into the what i call the digital
gulag like you know and doing work
google i used to love google they had it
was great it it try to do
a google search on climate gender or
race
and you will see how incredibly skewed
their algorithms are now
i mean
it it you know there are certain topics
where i just go to another another
search engine because i even though i
think google may be
more efficient
it it has been completely taken over and
it and you know unfortunately many of
the people running on tech companies
they don't really believe in the in the
first amendment anyway so you know and
they probably wouldn't even know what it
was
well joel we promised to ask you one
last question that ended up being an
extra 15 minutes so thank you for being
so generous with your time with your
time we're going to ask you a couple of
questions for our locals only supporters
that only they will see but for now
thank you so much for joining us i
really recommend everybody read the
coming of neo feudalism
and really appreciate where can people
find your other work online
i have a website joelcotkin.com plus um
i run a website called newgeography.com
which
runs all my stuff but also runs a lot of
other stuff as well
fantastic well thanks again for coming
on and thank you guys for watching and
listening we will see you very soon with
another brilliant episode and of course
on locals for the extra questions and
for those who like your trigonometry on
the go it's also available as a podcast
take care and see you soon guys
[Music]
did you ask what we the people can do to
stop the slide into neo-feudalism if
it's not too late
[Music]
you